[Music]
okay i have another um
sort of uh genius or idiot thing
did you see that logan paul was at
wrestlemania genius i did and i watched
it it was awesome
and it's actually not a part of genius
or idiot this is actually a part of like
a different question is logan paul the
greatest athlete of our generation did
you see this video so he looked great he
looked so good he looked amazing so so
he did up three suplexes in a row
i haven't watched wrestling since
like 20 years wrestling is back
wrestling is like booming wrestling is
[__] back dude is back in a huge way
and i think there's a lot of
opportunities around the fact that
wrestling is back and but the whole
world has changed it's like wrestling is
back but the entire world and the way it
works has changed and so that to me says
there's a lot of opportunity because
like you have crazy fandom and passion
but like all new like tools at your
disposal for like how you could like
harness that energy so they did
wrestlemania yesterday and whatever i
saw a bunch of clips you know stone cold
steve austin came back and drank a bunch
of beers uh pat mcafee was also a
podcaster somehow was like a key person
in the thing i don't know why somebody
can explain that to me but
logan paul did a match and ben if you
pull up the clip of logan paul in this
wrestling match
unbelievable athlete
absolutely unbelievable yeah it was
amazing and he did all the acting and
stuff he didn't he killed it yeah dude
they killed it i thought that was really
good by the way not easy to do what he
was doing what's it called it's not the
wwf wwe i think they uh that's a
publicly traded company yeah and so you
could like and you can buy it by their
stock and it's a killer business
they crush it
yeah i mean vince mcmahon is kind of an
unbelievable story in and of itself but
incredible athlete and a great crossover
move the paul brothers continue
to just not miss so i think you know i
think
like logan paul i think his podcast now
one of the most popular podcasts in the
world and more importantly than like ah
the paul brothers did something and i
got a bunch of views like that's a good
podcast though
but it's a good podcast and it's actual
it's actually entertaining content it's
actually like deeper content they talk
to all different types of people from
like business people musicians
porn stars they've had like all
different types of people and they have
like full-on conversations so then it's
a rebrand right it's like basically
taking this guy used to be a vine star
making fart jokes
and now you see
you know a more mellow side and a more
thoughtful side and all this other stuff
um
that's not him uh
now i'm just watching wrestlemania which
is also good in its own way look at him
he is yolked
logan paul is yoked yeah and as a kid i
remember watching this look at him do
all that [__] do you dude these guys are
basically bodybuilders who
have personalities they are so freaking
big
they're bodybuilders that are soap opera
actors that also can do are like also
like cirque du soleil acrobats basically
dude they're unicorns
he did uh like some crazy [__] in this
match anyways people should go watch it
it's honestly impressive just to see the
physical feat that he pulled off in this
thing um
so i thought that was impressive and i
also think it's a smart move for an
influence like this was not what they've
done with like going into celebrity
boxing
deep podcasting they've won crypto nfts
pokemon cards and then going into uh
like jake has a venture fund logan is
going to wwe now and like building his
character up there they're talking about
potentially doing a ufc fight like these
guys have like these guys are winning
man they're winning at like a very high
level that is very impressive to me um
and you know
most people just write them off like
they're idiots they're not idiots these
guys are awesome the thing about logan
is i actually like i've been watching
his podcast he like he's he's done a
really good job of rebranding himself he
is
he still has a little bit but he's
mostly he's not like a douche he's not a
bro he's super thoughtful he's he seems
like a really nice person he's the
respectful one on the podcast you guys
kind of goofball friends that are like a
little more brash and annoying they can
ask questions and like joke around about
stuff but he's the more reserved almost
like introverted like thoughtful 26
mature person 25 he's not that old but
he like he like gives advice like uh he
seems like he's just it's there's a lot
of stuff there that's rooted in pretty
good values you could just tell that his
brother i don't pay attention to as much
but logan i definitely um have been
watching his stuff and he seems very
very uh like a good dude
[Music]
you